let me ask you
about kankeezy a little bit longer
because the fascinating human being
he was also part of project mk ultra
yeah
yes what was project mk ultra and what
lessons we should take away from it
well mk ultra was a program
by the caa you know what they were
looking at was
can you take these drugs these
psychedelic drugs
and weaponize them in different ways
um for interrogation for true serums for
um
you know exposing somebody before they
give a big talk to something like lsd
and then they you know can't talk or
make a fool of themselves or
can you spray lsd over the battlefield
and have everybody tripping and drop
their weapons and then you just walk up
and you know nobody dies and you've won
you know the battle so so it's a
fascinating concept
yeah they called it non-lethal
incapacitance and i think that's
how uh one way to win a war is uh to
enforce peace
to get everybody not caring about the
war but yes well i
think gandhi said something even better
which is that the true way to win a war
is to turn your enemy into your friend
yes that's a beautiful way to put it
yeah um but
mk ultra was really nefarious and it was
part of our military and it was done in
secret and
they would um dose people against their
will
i mean one of the most infamous things
was that they had a house of
prostitution in san francisco and they
would
have one-way mirrors all this stuff and
then they would just uh dose people with
lsd
uh and they would have the prostitutes
dose these guys with lsd and and observe
what they would do and how they would
act and
um the ca actually for a while was
dosing each other
secretly and that there's a famous case
of this phil
olsen that um either jumped out of a
window or was pushed
he might have been killed um he was a
cia guy and they they
gave him lsd and then they're trying to
see
um can they break them down and get him
to tell secrets and i think he felt
uncomfortable with what happened to him
while he's under the influence of lsd
and
whether he was pushed or or not i don't
know if we'll ever know
but mk ultra was
[Music]
violating people's human rights it was
done in secret and
the irony of it is that ken kesey
is one of the people one of the main
early people that got lsd in this
context
and then he was one of the main people
that helped
inspire the hippies to use psychedelics
to oppose the vietnam war
so i think the cia kind of
in many cases things get out of their
control
what they think they can do and it
turned into be
a disaster for them i think there was
some thought that some of the people
at the cia had is that if you can turn
people inside
you know take drugs and they just focus
on their internal experience they're not
going to be involved politically
it's a way to sort of take people
offline
and what i don't think they counted on
is that when you're offline and you have
these unit of spiritual experiences
and you realize how we're all connected
then why do you want to
go out and kill these vietnamese and put
a
one dictator over another dictator
dictators on both sides in north vietnam
and south vietnam why are we doing that
so mk ultra has um
just very disreputable we're learning
more and more about what they did
and one of the unintended consequences
was ken kesey and
not only that but then the grateful dead
who began at the acid test that gizzy
was
helping to organize um and out of that
emerged
you could say just this incredible
psychedelic culture and you look at the
bands that began
in the 60s yes and which ones have
really survived to the
this day and um you know the grateful
dead
has survived longer than almost any
other band i mean some of them have died
and all but but it was like the
tightness the
the sort of telepathy we talked about
before that they
could just get so tuned in to each other
and each other's energies and they could
do improvisations and they could do this
incredible
work that i think the the the
sustainability of the grateful dead as a
group was a testimony testament to the
power of the lsd
experiences and that might have never
happened if not for mk ultra
you